Voiceover: What we're going
to talk about in this video
are the negatives of
fractional reserve lending.
And the biggest negative of
fractional reserve lending,
and these are all related,
is that it's fundamentally unstable
unless you have a lot of engineering
on the part of central
banks and governments
to make it more stable.
Unnatural things have to be put
in place to make it stable.
And the reason why I say it's unstable
is because all of these
depositors have been promised
that their money is safe and sound,
that at any point they
can come to the bank
and get their money. It's on demand.
But a good fraction of that
money is being lent out.
You can imagine, let's say
that all of these banks
are lending out the money responsibly,
but let's say this bank
something shady happens.
It lends out money in a really bad way
and it doesn't get it back,
or maybe it's even worse.
Maybe there's some type
of fraud taking place
where executives were embezzling money.
Whatever. These are good
actors within a fractional
reserve lending system.
This is a bad actor.
It made a bad loan.
Now all of a sudden this money is gone.
If you don't have any support from central
banks or from governments,
now all of these customers
are going to say,
"Wait, I heard something
shady happened at this bank."
They're all going to show up at this bank
all on the same day and
they're going to say,
"Give us back our money."
Then it will be pretty
clear that their money
actually was not available,
that it was lent out, some of it was lost.
They will be very upset,
these people right over here.
It's not just bad for this bank.
It doesn't even have to be that this bank
actually did anything fundamentally bad.
If even rumors start to spread
that something at this bank
is a little bit fishy,
you could imagine every one
of these bank's customers
showing up when that news
report hits and says,
"Give us back our money."
They'll say, "Well I can give
you back 10% of your money.
"The other 90% has been lent out."
That won't just affect this bank.
As soon as these people
try to go get their money
and they're not able to see it,
then the rest of the economy,
all the other actors in it will say,
"Wow, the banking system isn't
as solid as I thought it was."
So all of these other banks,
and maybe there wasn't
any news report written
about them and they
didn't do anything shady.
All of their customers are
going to start showing up.
They're going to say,
"Well, you promised me
"that my money is available on demand,
"well I'm demanding it right now."
Of course they're not
going to be able to get it
because their money was being lent out.
The situation that you
have right here is called
a run on banks.
You know banks lent out 90% of the money
and so really people
cannot get access to it.
You can imagine this is a
very, very, very bad situation.
You can have major bank failures.
A lot of lending starts to be ...
The whole banking system
essentially has to unwind
in some way and it would probably throw
the economy as a whole into something
of a downward spiral.
So the way that governments
attempt to address this issue
and in particular it's
usually the Central Bank,
is they say, "Okay we'll insure banks."
That's why you'll often
see at the front door
of a bank you'll see FDIC,
which means Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation,
which means that the
federal reserve is insuring
that bank.
So for whatever reason,
it's usually up to some
amount of deposits,
if one of these scenarios happens
and the bank does not
have the money on hand,
the Federal Reserve will say,
"Okay, we'll just make sure
that you have the money."
It's not an easy process
and it takes some time
but eventually the Federal
Reserve will give them the money.
But that by itself
creates another problem.
So that creates really the second problem
is bad incentive, or nonmarket,
I would say discipline.
Bad incentives.
Because in a traditional
system if I was giving
my money to someone and
they were going to go
and lend it to someone else,
I would really care how
they're lending that money.
I would really care how they're managing
their business.
I would want transparency in terms of what
investments they're making and
how safe they are etc, etc.
But in a situation where
all of the banks have this
FDIC insurance,
they essentially are back
stopped by the government.
Now all of the sudden when
customers go to the bank
they're like, "You know
what? I really don't
"care what you do with my money.
"I have FDIC banking so all I really care
"about is if you have cute kittens on your
"checkbooks and you have lots of ATMs.
"You have very impressive
looking buildings."
They really wouldn't
scrutinize the financials.
So you don't have that
market incentive anymore
for banks to say, "Hey
look, we are good shepherds
"of your money.
"Look at where your
assets are being spent.
"We want the market to scrutinize us onto
"whether we are making good loans
"or we are making bad loans."
The third problem with
fractional reserve lending
is that because of
fractional reserve lending,
you're giving the private banking system
a good deal of control
over the money supply.
If they lend more,
so lending translates into
more money in the money supply
or the other way around,
if lending were to go away,
that would mean contraction of
money in the lending supply.
The problem with this is
when the economy is weak.
Let's say you have a recession,
standard monetary policy
arguments you would say,
you want to increase the money supply.
Maybe you want to lower
interest rates so that
people will borrow and start
to consume or invest again.
So you want during a
recession, you want more money.
What's going to happen?
Central Bank tends to do that.
When it is clear that
it is in a recession,
the Central Bank will
attempt to print more money.
But in a fractional
reserve lending system,
that's only part of the
money supply equation.
You also have the lending and
when you're in a recession,
lending goes back.
So this is what you want.
You want this.
Central Bank might do it.
That is what you want.
The reality is in a recession the banks
are going to get scared.
They're going to see their loans go bad
and you have less lending.
It's going to essentially have the exact
opposite effect of what you want.
You're going to have less, and
I should put money in quotes.
It depends on how you define money
but you have less money in circulation.
The opposite happens in the boom.
The economy is down
and out in a recession.
It's going to be even worse
when that lending dries up.
There's going to be even
less money in circulation.
It's going to be even harder for people
to get access to capital.
The opposite is true in a boom.
I'm running out of real
estate on my screen.
In a boom when the economy is
well heated or overheating,
Central Bank will say,
"Hey let me take a little
"bit of that fuel out of the fire."
So what you want is less
money and Central Bank
might do that by taking
securities it owns,
selling it in the open market
and then it takes that cash and it could
even discontinue that cash,
and that's what Central Bank could do.
Central Bank could actually act on this.
In a boom banks get even more confident.
They get less risk and
start understating the risk
and so the reality is
you have more lending.
It essentially puts more
... which is more money.
More money in the system and essentially
adding more fuels to the flame
in an economy that is
already getting overheated.
So a lot of times this
fractional reserve lending
might lead to the money creation process
going in the exact opposite
direction that you want
it to go if you really wanted to moderate
the fluctuations in the economy.